concerns over low water levels at lake
mead making headlines today thank you
for staying with us here at 4 30 i'm
kirsten joyce and i'm christian casadas
well there has been so much discussion
about the colorado river and the water
levels in lake mead on wednesday the
water level mark sat at
1049 feet and one month ago it was at
1042 feet now the increase is all due to
the recent storms and you can see just
how far the colorado river stretches
among the seven states here including of
course ours that's right well one
non-profit group says that our problem
here for our water situation all comes
from an antique plumbing at the glen
canyon dam which is just lake uh near
lake powell
and now it's time to come up with a
solution to combat the water supply
crisis that's right
the system needs flexibility and it
needs flexibility now environmental
advocates sounding the alarm on the
water supply crisis from the colorado
river which impacts lake mead and
southern nevada residents the bureau of
reclamation
unveiled the call to congress
for the seven basin states to come up
with a plan within just 60 days to cut
between two and four million acre feet
of water from the colorado river basin
zachary frankel is the executive
director for the utah rivers council he
says the water problem stems from old
plumbing at the glen canyon dam near
lake powell
even though someone in las vegas might
not know anything or care much about
what's happening at glen canyon dams the
problem is
that the antique plumbing inside glen
canyon dam is has the potential to
prevent
las vegas and nevada from getting its
full water supply out of the colorado
river now a coalition of several
agencies is recommending two possible
solutions either whitening or drill
additional tubes to increase the water
flow or construct new bypass tunnels to
rise the river level once the water
level starts dropping another 45 feet
we're going to have major water supply
delivery problems
to 30 million people it's unclear how
much the repair cost would be but frank
hell and the coalition want congress to
fund a study soon before it's too late
this really should have happened five
years
ago well the bureau of reclamation's
deadline for all seven states including
nevada is on august 15th now if the
states do not identify a plan to cut
water use the bureau says it will use
its authority to impose huge water cuts
on all the states now also be on the
lookout for this flyer right here in
your mailbox the southern nevada water
authority wants to remind all residents
about the water situation at lake mead